PROFESSOR: So now
let's summarize
where we've come to in our
analysis of short-range effects
from respiratory jets
relative to long range
airborne transmission which
we previously calculated.
And let's also
think about what are
the implications for policy.
And for personal decisions about
safety during the pandemic.
So first of all,
when masks are worn,
we've already discussed the
filtering effect of masks.
We've talked about
how that brings
a squared factor of the
mask penetration factor
which leads to a very
substantial increase
in the reduction in
the transmission rate.
But there's another
important factor
when you have a mask, even a
fairly poor mask, a cloth mask,
it may not be so great a
blocking aerosol particles
but it's very good
at blocking momentum
so the fluid momentum that
comes from just normal breathing
is almost completely
stopped by a mask.
Even a vigorous cough only
lets some momentum through
and a few droplets from
more violent activities
such as that.
So what's more typical in a case
where people are wearing masks
is that there is sort of
some exhaled air slowly
building up around you without
very much additional momentum.
And as we've discussed that air
is warmer and tends to rise.
And so typically
the thermal plume
of kind of the exhaled
air rising above you a bit
like a chimney and that's where
the droplets initially reside.
We're not likely to directly
infect anybody by that method,
either because people
aren't close enough
or they aren't above
the other person.
And then, of course,
there are other flows
in the room that
we've discussed,
which are often turbulent.
And those will transport
the droplets everywhere
and will lead to
the well-mixed room
as being the most
natural and most accurate
first approximation
for the infection risk
by another person who
is also wearing a mask.
So I would argue that no
strict social distancing is
required in a mask situation.
So whether we're six
feet or three feet,
it's not going to give us
substantially more safety
if people are wearing masks.
And instead we should pay much
more attention to the formula
that I boxed here,
which gives you
an estimate of the long range
transmission risks airborne
which is equally there
for everyone in the room.
And that must be
considered for safety
and also for contact tracing.
Now situation is very
different without masks.
As we've seen without masks, we
are imparting a lot of momentum
to the fluid, the air.
Simply by breathing
and certainly
by talking or singing
or exercising,
we're really pushing the
air around and launching
those particles into the air.
And even at three
feet or six feet
there can be still
a substantial risk.
Although as we
said, the difference
between three and
six is not so great.
So one might consider
switching to three.
On the other, hand,
even six may not
be enough protection you
might need to be thinking
about longer distancing.
And of course, there is
always the airborne risk.
So at some point, you
hit that point x_c
where the airborne risk is
comparable to the short-range
risk.
And also there are people such
as the guy I sketched back here
which are not in
the respiratory jet
and probably have a lower
risk than the average.
So it's definitely
important to still consider
the average risk coming from
the long range guideline.
But one could add a correction
to be very conservative
for cases such as sketched
here when this poor person is
finding himself or herself
in the respiratory jet
for long periods of time.
So let's imagine there's a
typical spacing, x bar, which
would be sort of the
worst case but still
typical spacing one might expect
of the people in the rooms.
If you think there's a
certain situation where
maybe two of the people might
be five feet apart or four,
three feet apart and
facing each other
for sniffing amounts
of time, and then p jet
is the probability that
they are encountering
each other's respiratory jets.
Or maybe put another
way, the fraction
of the time one person
spends in another person's
respiratory jet.
When that happens
the transmission
is just between two people.
It's not to the entire room.
So that's another very important
factor to keep in mind,
this factor of n, the
occupancy, doesn't really
come up in the social
distancing model
here when we're talking about
the indoor reproductive number.
So to make a modified
guideline, we
can take the long range
indoor reproductive number
and add a short
range correction.
We've already calculated
what this looks like.
So if I write the
guideline as n minus 1 tau
is less than epsilon
over the average beta,
I can also restore
what that means here.
Average beta times tau is the
integral, time interval data,
basically, of the
transmission rate.
And so this fact
that we've already
calculated the ratio
of the shortrange term
to the longer term
is x_c over x--
or x bar times p jet.
It's a very simple correction.
If we plug back in our estimates
for this average beta then
we arrive at this formula here.
The first term is the same
guideline we already have.
And there's a new term
now which, notice,
does not involve n and
doesn't have the mass factor,
of course, as well.
But it involves the length,
so social distancing.
And it involves the mouth
area and the breathing rate.
The breathing rate
now is also not
coming in square
because we're assuming
that the breath is already
providing this concentration.
And we're just looking at
another distance downstream.
And the Qb is for the receiving
person's inhaling breath rate
whereas the QB squared comes
from inhaling and exhaling
and finding the steady
state in the room.
And so we've already
estimated how big
this term is [? xc ?]
over x might be anywhere
from one to 100 or maybe even
1,000 if you let p jet be 1.
So if you stand facing
another person continuously,
this can be a large term and
can actually dominate the other.
I'll notice there's an n there.
So still, there
could be a balance.
But when you take into account
that people are not always
directly facing
each other so much,
then this number might
be a lot smaller.
And I would argue
that in many cases
the dominant term is
the long range one.
And the short range
one is the correction.
But one should be
aware of situations
where the short-range
effect could be dominant.
And so that must
also be considered.
And this modified guideline
here would be one way
to take that into account.